democrats set to take control of the
senate after winning the
two georgia runoff races it will make it
much easier for joe biden to pass his
agenda and he is already being pressured
from the far left to bring quote
transformative
change so dana you've been preparing for
two months to talk about the georgia
race and the
results i'll go to you first all right
well you know first of all i
usually have pretty good predictions i
missed on both of these i said that i
thought that the republicans would win
by just a whisker
instead it was the other way around i
did think that
if they were they were either going to
lose both or win both
i thought they would win both and they
didn't but there weren't a lot of ticket
splitters something that's interesting
katie
is that white women and college-educated
suburban voters
came back to the republicans in these
runoffs and they had big turnout there
and that was good but
what happened was that in ruby red
counties or districts those voters did
not show up
and i've been saying that you know 24
500 registered republican voters voted
in the primary in 2020
did not vote in the general so there is
something happening that
these voters feel like there's it's not
worth it to come out or they
didn't want to do it or they didn't like
the candidates something
happened there and i have a friend that
works in republican
politics and worked on these races and
he said you know we lost to two terrible
candidates
and we better learn something from it
yeah greg i'm going to make a prediction
uh the senate is now split 50 50 but i
think that the left is going to act like
this is a mandate and that they won 10
seats
i agree completely my product they uh
they control
the senate they control the house and
they control
a very weak president right they control
him
so my prediction is there will be no
calls for unity
there will be no move to the center
though there will be no hey
we're all americans let's get along
they're going to exercise
raw power and they're going to use
yesterday's events
as their excuse to go in hard and you're
going to see this happen
fast they were already making lists of
how to punish trump supporters
well before this we we reported on that
so you think it's going to get better
because no
yesterday gave them an opportunity to go
even harder on the people they hate
which is you
so juan democrats were successful in
turning out the vote they've also
changed the map in a lot of places since
the last presidential election
what do you see for the senate the new
senate in the next couple of weeks
well i think it's 50 50. i think you can
anticipate there's going to be an effort
to get out those checks to people
stimulate the economy help the economy
get going
but i just want to say right off the top
there katie that
you know elections do have consequences
and one of them we saw today i think
merrick garland being selected by joe
biden
as the next attorney general is a
function of the fact that with
a democratic majority in the senate he
can now appoint
a democrat leaning judge to replace
merrick garland on the d.c
court of appeals and have garland as
attorney general i don't think
garland would have been selected unless
you had democrats
having at least a 50-50 split in the
senate
all right jesse sorry we have to run one
more thing stop next